[Music]
and was it worth it news always was it
submitted by Korean dad a restaurant
working with glad wrap pissed off food
critics for a brand deal what I don't
understand
glad Rock meaning the the saran wrap
like the garbage bag okay they were
doing a brand deal in the restaurant
yeah like the glad products yeah
so this restaurant in Chicago which is a
critically acclaimed restaurant they
hosted a select group of diners
including feat food media everything to
say pedia cuz they were gonna feed them
you know yeah yeah that's awesome
anyway so then they were under the
impression that there would be a first
to try a Beard Award nominated chef
named Jason Vince's new menu so they
were gonna try this new menu what the
[ __ ] is very confusing I'm assuming that
there's a reward for beards or like I
don't know like an actual physical mate
beer let's just say there's a committee
that awards this I think it's not even
for beards and that's what I'm
disappointed about we think beers are
beards Abbi you're done you're done here
I think is it like the Zagat Zagat
Survey or war thing or no talking about
all this restaurant law we're [ __ ]
Saget
we're huge daggers yeah we're a bunch of
Zagat's over here yeah I know like we're
even bigger Zagat sorry it's a culinary
award no see I knew it wasn't beard
what the hell with the word what your
word is did cool in their excellence in
cuisine :
anyway the point is this chef has won an
award and he was gonna present a new
menu so yeah all these people come over
to check out this new move the
invitation informed diners that there
would be cameras recording content and
but they didn't describe what the meal
was gonna be Dave did say it was gonna
be complimentary and so what they ended
up doing was that they prepared this
entire meal three days before the event
and then they rs.20 with glad products
plastic wrap which is part of the brand
deal thing and then they presented it to
the diners without telling them anything
beforehand and then they ate the food
and then after surprise well now it's
like surprises three days old and
everyone's like [ __ ] you viscosity Oh
cuz aren't they trying to prove like how
fresh it'll stretch it keeps it yeah
that's not good and so exactly there's
not bad
no that's pretty that's pretty bad would
you leave for three days no I mean it's
in the fridge right yes I'm assuming but
you think you're gonna get this
experience from this Zagat approved is a
huge ayah is a huge there's a huge
difference between fresh restaurant food
that comes out I get if you have
something as leftovers and it's leftover
mentality one day two days three days
five days tastes the same but when you
go to in-and-out or McDonald's to get
french fries you want it and then you
have it glad wrapped for three days it's
gonna take whoa and if they don't
they're telling me Gordon Ramsay making
me something and then Gordon brands he
comes out he's like you just ate
leftovers I'm like enjoy I just feel
like what I think is like you know
you're expecting this like gourmet chef
experience and the plates and the
silverware and everything is all fancy
and then they're like presenting and
there's just saran wrap and like the
sauce don't writing on top of the saran
wrap I would be laughing my ass like
that would be solid funny well because
I'm not paying for it right they're
presented with the rep oh it was it well
okay it was like here's the food enjoy
you think they just gave him a trash bag
of food cuz that'll be great yeah that
would be her laughs
that would be ain't gonna write like it
comes in a [ __ ] sly column you got to
unwrap it yourself [ __ ] it's chilly in a
trash bag they just taste it then that
the food was old yeah cuz it no no so
then after the meal was over that's when
they told that see I would be offended
about the brand deal thing is like man I
didn't get paid for this and you used me
and [ __ ] as one of your [ __ ] actors
and [ __ ] that's [ __ ] up right but then
the whole experience sounds kind of fun
I wish I was in the room when that
information was disclosed right like it
was like oh man and it fit like that was
actually three days old and they're like
vert izing and this isn't it's not glads
fault like like I think they should have
a commercial where somebody takes
something out of the fridge it's got
glad wrap on it they open it and they go
wrap in your life call us today 1-800 it
in there for two weeks and then be
surprised when it smells bad glad don't
finish it I mean to be fair I don't now
thinking about it I don't think it's
that big of a deal
within these people are getting paid to
eat the food we're getting paper this
becomes real there's some foods that
taste really good when it's old like
like curry rice fresh cooking normally
needs like a day or two to really set
pause on it
pozole soups yeah I mean like of course
breads and stuff you can't really do it
right but so where people pissed butter
yeah they felt duped they felt like oh
so those is one person that said that
what he's doing is unethical and
potentially a violation of his license
wait for it emotional distress exactly
you know what probably happened so he
got all these pretentious little [ __ ]
food bloggers right right they started
quoting about like how great the food
was and all this [ __ ] and then guess
what it's three days old and then they
feel [ __ ] humiliated so now they're
firing back well I forgot to mention -
so they did have this consent form and
if they signed it they would be paid
$300 and if they would they would get
$1,000 if glad used them in the video we
should glide had to get Lydia to get rid
of this whole thing know something thing
got rid of it is just well actually I'm
not sure but it's just that this whole
thing sparked negative reactions toward
this restaurant or just called Giants
and towards this chef because it's a
whole fact that they didn't disclose
this beforehand to people which is
important and so by the way the word but
ruins the surprise though so there were
two sessions there are two to eating
sessions and the first one that's when
people from the second session session
found out about the first one the fact
that they were eating food that was
three days old because they were having
like the people for the second session
we're having some of them were having
drinks at a bar nearby and then they
heard when the first session people came
out they're like what the [ __ ] we just
ate three days old for the second
session instead of being like surprised
you're eating old food they did tell
people this food and you should have
just done this this would have solved
all issues they could have still kept it
a secret but you disclose you're about
to eat fresh food versus three days old
food tell me what the difference is you
taste the difference they should follow
these people with cameras for three days
and just see what the [ __ ] they're
eating at home
I guarantee either eating [ __ ] Oreos
and [ __ ] stale chips that have been
there for like six months
exactly days is not bad no they're
acting like it's like rotten food that's
like a month old they're acting like
they're [ __ ] there they're in The
Hunger Games and they're those people in
the rich town and they only like caviar
[ __ ] if I'm going to a restaurant for an
event like this I don't want to eat
three-day food port it's free geo it's
free so let me leave put into
perspective okay what about aged steak -
it's like 30 days when you burger days
old its part but then with cheese I'm
already told this information so my mind
is already
there's fermented minutes hold right and
I have a better marketing campaign
that's here so what they're trying to do
is trying to show you how airtight or
how fresh this [ __ ] gladware is right
and they're trying to cover food up and
trying to see okay three days it lasts
that long I think a better one to be you
have someone take a [ __ ] in the saran
wrap right you wrap it up any go here
see if you can smell it through this and
if you're holding a piece of [ __ ] you're
just smelling it and you're like damn I
really can't smell it you with these
[ __ ] crazy ideas but I'm [ __ ] with
you on this one there's a [ __ ] but I
have to prevents the [ __ ] smell from
coming up I would buy it then it's gonna
definitely keep the freshness in you
ever had a watermelon wrapped in saran
wrap at the grocery store I likes
putting my nose up to the saran wrap cuz
I could smell it through I could smell
the water but if you could if you
couldn't smell it but if you couldn't be
no it's airtight for this commercial
just to up the stakes a little bit yeah
they should get like a like a [ __ ]
huge dude - it's like he ate nothing but
egg salad sandwiches and now he's taking
a dump in this bag and then it's like
and now his mom is gonna try to smell
damn if she can smell it and then she
smells it and if she [ __ ] just falls
over
we know that glad doesn't work but we
know that the stakes it's like if you we
don't want his sweet mother to smell his
[ __ ] even if even the mother can't take
it who else can Oh even better
let's keep everything the same but
instead of three-day old food we get a
year old food that's rotten and but
people eat it right and then people
think the brand deal is about the glad
[ __ ] saran wrap but no the real brand
deals when they puke and then you go
contain the Pew they're puking in / yeah
and it smells great because you know how
they have immune system I don't know
where you're going with that but you
know how like the glad a [ __ ] liner
right it's like scented now it smells
great so it's like glad not only does it
hold your puke but it smells great yeah
why do these companies not know that
people use their products for disgusting
things I only use glass for disgusting
things silverware in there what is it
they know that's why they sent it no I
know in the commercials and something
never matches the actual use do you want
to put into fine dining
like which fine dining restaurant has
[ __ ] Tupperware right like we should
take it to take it like like pass it out
to a homeless people and have them play
with the focus or not yeah I like that
and if it were and if you got a homeless
guy who's like if you have a homeless
guy that goes when I need a cape glad
wear capes yeah cuz they're the ones
that lasted long he's like if I need a
cape that turns into a roof in a
moment's notice every time never stand
outside of a Vegas club in the middle of
the night and while people come out and
start puking just grab that bag and be
like BAM
glad you smell it just so we did that
for tips
we spoke barf bag holder that's why I'm
in one of those Vegas bathrooms and
there's a guy in there you know back in
a day like old old old like Europe
people used to walk around with a bucket
right in a big [ __ ] coat and then if
you needed to take a [ __ ] or whatever
they put the bucket down you should you
sit on the bucket and he covers you
guess what public restrooms means that
that whole family has no job no jobs
anymore he's a hoarder potty robots are
taking over the industry
[Laughter]
last name reflects on like your
ancestors jobs and maybe the porters the
porters are just party might change do
you know a bunch of will they come over
they want to they don't want to face
persecution they change the name yeah do
you think the porters ever came home
back from a hard day in the 1800 and and
it's like oh how is what today is like
you know someone got a little bit on me
[Music]